enfin ce gouvernement aiment-ils les
français de l'étranger
vous me permettrez d'en douter en
matière fiscale entre autres des
centaines de compatriotes relayés par
leurs élus m'interpelle sur leurs
inquiétudes quant à l'augmentation
faramineuse de leurs impôts vous êtes à
l'origine de ce qu'ils décrivent comme
une catastrophe fiscale j'ai deux
questions premièrement les français de
l'étranger sont soumis aux prélèvements
sociaux csg crds et prélèvements de
solidarité soit 17,1 pour cent alors
qu'il ne bénéficie d'aucune prestation
sociale en france
à ceci s'ajoute une discrimination entre
les français résidant dans lieux et ceux
résidant hors heu
ceux qui résident dans lieu en raison de
votre refus de supprimer ces
prélèvements ont saisi la cour de
justice de l'ue eux et ils ont gagné
ils sont donc exemptés vous avez refusé
d'appliquer la même règle à ceux qui
résident hors ue27 innues donc à être
soumis à ce prélèvement de 17,20 %
pourquoi cette double injustice
deuxièmement compte tenu qu'on ceux
concernant la retenue à la source
vous avez augmenté le taux minimum de 20
à 30 % auxquels il faut ajouter pour les
résidents auront eu le pré 9le
prélèvements csg crds et le prélèvement
de solidarité soit 17,20 % pour les
revenus inférieurs à 27000 519 euros la
retenue à la source et de 27 5% pour les
résidents d'ems lieux et de 37,5 % pour
ceux résidant hors eu lieu sur ceux dont
les revenus sont supérieurs à 27 milles
519 euros soit 2300 euros par mois la
retenue à la source sera de 37,5 pour
cent pour les résidents d'ems lieux et
de 47,20 % pour ceux résidant hors ue27
hors application note aux moyens s'ils
acceptent de déclarer leurs revenus
mondiaux
pourquoi cet autre discrimination pour
répondre monsieur